apple's march 8th event is happening
tomorrow morning and i can't even begin
to explain how excited i am because
after apple sent out their invites for
the event we continued to get bombshell
leaks and rumors that completely changed
our expectations for what we could be
seeing at this event so in this video
i'm gonna go through these leaks and
explain my predictions for tomorrow's
event including which max i think are
the most likely to get released but
before i get into all of that i've got
to discuss some new discoveries in terms
of what apple's peak performance
invitation is actually supposed to mean
because in the video that i made last
week i mentioned that peak performance
was supposed to signify apple releasing
a brand new apple silicon chip and a lot
of you guys slammed me for not realizing
that they spelt peak with two e's which
means that it's more likely sneak peek
and don't worry i noticed that from the
beginning and i fully understand it but
my point was that peak performance is a
common term to symbolize the best of the
best performance and that's what i think
apple is going after and if you don't
believe me a bunch of people on twitter
posted their foreign apple invites that
confirm that apple is actually talking
about performance for example the
brazilian invitation literally means an
unprecedented performance or in other
words performance that has never been
seen or done before and then in turkish
the invite says our performance is about
to begin which kind of symbolizes that
apple is just getting started in terms
of performance kind of like we haven't
seen anything yet even though apple's m1
max is already powerful it's nothing
compared to the performance apple is
about to show us and then finally the
german invite says our imagination of
performance or kind of like the
performance that apple has always
imagined and strived for finally being
here so based on all those multinational
invitations i think it's safe to say
that the event is more about high
performance than the whole peak aspect
of it now before i get into what we
could possibly see in terms of a new
chip let me first refresh you guys on
what we should be expecting to see
tomorrow
first off we're going to be getting a
new iphone sc3 and according to sources
like ross young and michiko it's going
to have the same 4.7 inch display the
same home button and the same overall
design except with the new a15 chip and
5g support and we should also be
expecting a new ipad air 5 with the a15
chip 5g and potentially some features
like quad stereo speakers a new dual
camera design and a new purple color
according to luke miyani and on top of
that the iphone 13 is supposed to get a
new green color as well as a bunch of
new cases but all of that right there
isn't what this event is truly going to
be about because we're about to see a
bunch of new mac related products so
let's jump right into these leaks
first up we've been expecting apple's
new high-end mac mini ever since late
last year when it was delayed because
apple wanted to give more attention to
the new macbook pros so i fully believe
that we'll be seeing this new mac mini
at tomorrow's event packing the same m1
pro and m1 max chips that we already
have in the new macbook pros but other
than that apple did actually register
two more mac devices with the eec which
means that we could see these new macs
revealed at this event and thankfully we
got some huge leaks over the weekend
first up dan rue posted a tweet
mentioning that he heard from a source
that we could be getting a higher end
imac at this event but the weird thing
is that ming chakrow just tweeted his
expectations for mac releases this year
including a more powerful mac mini which
we were expecting and a new 27-inch
non-mini led display this year and then
both the imac pro and mac pro next year
and the key point is that ross young was
actually expecting the imac pro here in
the next couple of months as well as dan
rui who says an imac could be coming
tomorrow so in my opinion what we could
actually be seeing is a new 27-inch
high-end imac that is not an imac pro
but a new imac to fit the same m1 pro
and m1 max chips as the new high-end mac
mini will be getting and the craziest
thing of all is that over the weekend
mark german's power on newsletter
finally for the first time acknowledged
the possibility of having two different
27-inch imacs which is something that
i've been considering for months now and
he says we could be seeing a new imac
perhaps as soon as the first half of the
year while at the same time he doesn't
believe a new mac pro or imac pro is
ready to go on sale imminently matching
up to what mingxiquo said so with all of
that said a new imac is definitely a
possibility for tomorrow but on top of
that we got some major leaks this
morning in terms of apple releasing a
new studio 27 inch display tomorrow and
almost every source agrees with this
first of all nine to five max shared
some exclusive leaks late last week
concerning this new display coming
alongside a new mac studio which i'm
about to get into after this display and
then of course ming chakra already
mentioned it and then mark german
actually mentioned the same display
saying that apple has completed work on
it months ago and it could be ready to
launch at any moment even tomorrow but
then luke miani came out with some
exclusive leaks this morning saying that
he fully believes that this display is
coming at tomorrow's event and i think
with everything that we've been seeing
this display is coming for sure no doubt
about it and now before i get into the
absolute most surprising reveal at
tomorrow's event including my theory on
what it would actually be let me first
talk about the new expected m2 chip for
weeks now we've been getting a lot of
leaks concerning a new entry-level
macbook pro coming at this event
starting with a digit times report
earlier this year which at first didn't
really make any sense until more and
more leaks started to confirm this idea
especially the fact that one of the max
apple registered with the eec was
actually a laptop and then this weekend
mark german took things to a whole new
level by mentioning that apple has been
testing out multiple macs with a new
chip in recent weeks that includes an 8
core cpu and 10 core gpu which are
exactly the specs for the m2 chip
according to mark german and apparently
apple has been testing this new chip on
machines running mac os 12.3 12.4 and
the future mac os 13. so the idea is
that if apple was not planning on
releasing these new m2 max until wwdc
then why would they be testing it with a
version of mac os that's supposed to be
getting released as soon as next week
and then going further mark believes
that we'll be getting both m2 and m1 pro
m1 max model max all coming in the first
half of this year including mac minis
with both of those chips imax with up to
the m1 max and a new macbook pro with an
m2 chip all being spread out over the
next couple of months up until june so
before i give you my take on which ones
are coming when let's jump right into
the new mac studio this new mac showed
up last week with an exclusive leak from
9 to 5 mac claiming that it would sit
somewhere between the mac mini and the
mac pro and then luke miani came out
this morning and claimed that the new
max studio would be revealed at
tomorrow's event no doubt about it and i
actually believe him so let me explain
why first up 9 to 5 max says that apple
is working on two different versions of
this new mac studio with one of them
getting up to an m1 max chip while the
other will be getting an even more
powerful chip potentially the m1 max duo
and at first this was really weird to me
because i thought that the new high-end
mac mini was supposed to get the m1 pro
and m1 max chips so it wouldn't really
make sense for the max studio to also
start with the m1 max until i realized
something that should have been obvious
to me the entire time
what if this new mac studio is actually
the replacement for the high-end mac
mini because if you think about it the
redesigned mac mini renders that we were
seeing from sources like john prosser
and leeks apple pro came with a much
slimmer design language and the weirdest
part of all is that the cooling system
on those renders seemed to be inferior
for being able to cool the m1 max so
what if that new slim design is actually
only meant for the new lower end m2 chip
which uses a lot less power and that
would mean that apple would need a new
much larger mac mini design with
sufficient cooling capabilities exactly
like luke miyani's render show us with
tons of vents on the bottom being
perfect for the m1 max or maybe even an
m1 max duo and the idea i have is that
because this new design is much larger
than the mac mini apple cannot call it a
mini anymore and they also can't call it
a mac mini pro since it still has the
name mini in it and therefore they need
a brand new title the mac studio and in
my point of view this would make it a
lot easier for apple to market this new
mac because in the past there used to be
both a low end and a high-end mac mini
so it could get confusing if you're
trying to figure out if it's the weak
version or the powerful version but now
a mac studio will always be known as the
high-end pro version and the mac mini
will always be known as the lower end
consumer friendly version and since i
believe the mac studio is quite
literally the new high-end mac mini i
can basically guarantee that it is
coming tomorrow and with that said if
the new 27-inch apple display is in fact
called the studio display then it will
also 100 get released alongside the mac
studio because it just makes sense for
marketing but now we've got to figure
out what else we could be seeing at this
event because we could be getting two
more macs according to the eec filings
and in my opinion there are two
scenarios that could happen so let's get
into scenario number one there's a
chance that apple isn't ready to reveal
the m2 chip just yet and they could be
waiting until wwdc
so in that case i actually think that
apple could be releasing the new m1 pro
and m1 max 27 inch imac alongside the
mac studio and the studio display
however these products kind of
contradict each other because this imac
would essentially be the new mac studio
and studio display put together into one
machine so i'm not sure it makes sense
to release both of those ideas or macs
together so that brings us to scenario
number two i was looking at luke miani's
new mac studio renders and i noticed
that they look almost exactly like the
redesigned mac mini renders from last
year complete with the plexi glass top
but in a taller design with the extra
vents on the bottom so what if apple
decides to reveal both of these new mac
mini designs at the same time and they
can market them as the lower end
redesigned m2 mac mini with the small
design and the higher end m1 max studio
and then that would give them the chance
to properly explain the differences
between both chips so that people don't
get confused on why the m2 is slower and
maybe there's even a chance that this
new mac studio could come with a brand
new m1 max duo chip that we've been
talking about for a couple of months or
maybe even the new 12 core chip that
dylan dkt leaked before he left twitter
and this would actually make sense
considering the huge design of the mac
studio compared to the smaller mac mini
and then of course on top of that we
would also be getting the entry level m2
macbook pro which has been rumored for
months now and this would actually match
up to all three of the macs that apple
registered with the eec
and then a couple of months later apple
could release the high-end imac and then
in the fall release the rest of the m2
mac lineup including the macbook air and
the 24 inch imac however the only
problem with this second scenario is
that luke miani said that he had
exclusive info that pointed to no
macbook coming at all at this event so i
guess we're just gonna have to wait and
see what happens at tomorrow's event but
with that said go ahead and give me your
thoughts on what you think is gonna be
coming tomorrow and if you enjoyed this
video go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe so you don't miss out
on our coverage of this event and all
the new products and definitely check
out one of those two videos right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video